of the 50 US hospitals that charge the
most for their services 20 are located
in Florida all but one of them are
for-profit that's according to a recent
study in the journal Health Affairs it
finds that most states don't limit what
hospitals charge for their services and
that most charge more than three times
the Medicare allowable costs with some
charging upwards of ten times the rate
across the nation there's a push to
increase transparency in the hopes of
slowing down the increase in health
costs the study concludes that
exceptionally high medical bills may
lead vulnerable patients to either avoid
much-needed care or to declare personal
bankruptcy and Scarlett this is
interesting because you you can't help
but see the relationship between twenty
located in Florida and that's where a
lot of workers are yeah absolutely you
know it's interesting as community
health system which owns 20 of the
highest charging hospitals in that
survey said that the data used in the
survey was based on a price list that
doesn't reflect what people actually pay
so there's a published list and then
there's what people actually pay
that's very defense Gerard Anderson he's
a professor of a public health policy
and management
Johns Hopkins Bloomberg School of Public
Health he told our reporters all
hospitals mark it up but the for-profits
are doing it for a much higher rate than
the non profits you know I mean you and
I know this from having families and
everything you always can negotiate down
the fees at a hospital or a doctor's
office but it requires you actually
calling someone in making our case
absolutely